premiers au hit parade des meilleures
ventes chez les filles de 3 à 5 ans le
lot vise rien que dans ce magasin il
s'en est vendu plus de 400 pièces
une peluche interactive vendu 300 francs
plus en mains caressent plus elle parle
et si on est patient et la couche même
d'un bébé c'est un produit la toute
nouvelle génération qui fait suite aux
fermiers qu'on a connue l'an passé qui
est un petit peu plus perfectionnés qui
peut plus sophistiqués et c'est la
grande nouveauté cette année du moins
romantique plus agressif action man best
seller chez les garçons de 4 à 7 ans
c'est un peu le pendant de la poupée
barbie chez les filles ici pas loin de
2000 mannequins ont été vendus les
enfants adorent son univers fantastique
on reste dans l'univers du fantastique
avec les jeux vidéo un produit qui
s'adresse aux grands enfants de 13 ans à
plus de 30 ans qu'est ce qui te plaît
dans ce type de jeu c'est que les
graphismes et sons bien fait et
il ya beaucoup de jeu
si croirai quand on joue
enfin particularités du marché du jouet
cette année il a dû faire face à la
concurrence de la trottinette
il son chien chat les arts il se déplace
jour réclame à manger et s'il n'était
pas trouvé de plus électroniques ont les
confondrait passe avec les vraies
paroles d'enfants qui sont électroniques
et qui ont appuyé ça fait comme des
vrais animaux ça bouge dans tous les
sens c'est amusant et fieux il reconnaît
je la vois un total les vrais animaux et
c'est pas tous
qui font pas les besoins un peu partout
et qui est qui font pas pipi
si les enfants les ont complètement
adopté reste à convaincre les parents
les enfants on regarde le jouer jouer et
ils sont plutôt statique alors que
d'antan avec les jouets d'autrefois les
enfants devaient imaginer des jeux
imaginer des histoires celles à venir
donc il faut en passer par là aussi
virtuelle soit ils ses nouveaux
compagnons ne pourront cette année pas
nous échapper les distributeurs l'ont
bien compris et leur consacre un réel
espace aujourd'hui tous les jours on est
on est dans cette technologie dans notre
voiture dans notre cuisine et bien
maintenant dans les jouets c'est logique
les enfants bénéficient de la même
technologie les fabricants se sont
adaptés et sont capable maintenant de
proposer des produits à des prix qui
sont corrects et avec un premier prix
sous la barre des 200 francs ces
machines à quatre pattes devrait sans
problème trouver refuge le soir de noël
voilà ce qui me reste c'est d'ici
qu'est ce qu'il a exactement ici il me
reste trois références en harry potter
lego le reste tout le reste est parti ça
a eu un succès absolument extraordinaire
donc si vous n'avez pas compris on
répète c'est la grosse tendance et la
licence forte de la fin d'année c'est
c'est harry potter ce matin c'était
encore plein
ça on a été dévalisée si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi vous ne verrez donc ni
le château d'harry potter ni le train
d'harry potter n'y ait aucun des 50
autres produits dérivés du film ils sont
tous vendus d'ailleurs si on veut avoir
une petite chance avec la deuxième
grosse tendance de noël neutre et non
pas d'un point comme c'est un des
produits
enfin je dirais en termes de robots
c'est une petite merveille technologique
il en existait un autre qui s'appelle
haïti bis je les ai tous vendus
celui-ci vous voyez c'est le dernier je
pense que ce soir
il sera parti ce teckel robot presque
grandeur nature jaf renifle éternue et
peu développés 16 personnalités
différentes mais pas de panique les
enfants commandes encore il est bon
vieux playmobil la preuve
d'une semaine se cherche la maison j'ai
acheté les veillées les pièces de quoi
réchauffer maison contemporaine
désolé festoyer
toujours pas ici encore moins la à paris
comme en province les rayons étaient
dévalisés difficile nous dénicher la
perle rare je cherche karaoké que
l'enfant puisse lire les chansons sur la
télé et c'est ça que je n'arrive pas
apaiser un tapis
à mi corps
voici donc le jouer vedette de cette
année histoire de faire comme dans une
certaines académies pas en reste les
filles ont accepté de faire un bout
d'essai et pour elle aussi c'est du
sérieux
[Musique]
chan pourquoi
on
peut bien centrer mais avec un sac et
que c'est pas comme les autres jeux
l'autre joué fort le voici la toupie
télécommande et une vraie leçon de vie
c'est à peu près comme la vie
quoi qu'il y en a des gens qui sont
meilleurs toi et à chaque fois ils
veulent faire leur crâne heures et nous
battre et à modeler on les bat
un jean et une parka à la mode n'aura
sept ans s'habille comme ses idoles la
poupée de nos grands mères est prié
d'aller se rhabiller
j'essaie un peu de côté sur elle quand
même et puis ici et j'aimerais avoir
et un bonnet carmel parce que c'est très
joli heureux parents attendez vous à ce
que ça couine ce noël encore sous le
sapin ça va babiller chanté dansé
jusqu'au bout des piles seule
consolation les micros et karaoke numéro
un des ventes l'an dernier c'est un peu
terminé que des émissions dédiées à la
musique là il ya vraiment une baisse
cette année pour un retour sur des
produits plus classiques au niveau des
jouets plein écran chez les filles grand
classique le poupon clone du vrai bébé
interactive bien sûr il fait se
confondre les mamans petit l'air parfumé
une poupée à la 13
et c'est le triomphe assuré numéro un
des ventes de l'année comme cet autre
poupée dora passablement excités qui
parlent même anglais courage là et barco
des poupées mannequins c'est encore la
blonde américaine qu'on retrouve numéro
un la quarantaine toujours alerte ou la
reconnaissait barbie qui reste le numéro
1 des jouets jeux château
[Musique]
elle veut aussi la calèche le prince la
vente peut sérieusement talonné par
d'autres créatures moins blonde platine
et le lauquet deux influences des actes
et les réalités mais la star de noël
c'est un petit bijou de technologie un
humanoïde télécommande est capable une
fois programmé d'assumer les pires
corvée c'est papa qui est ravi il peut
par exemple aller baranger la chambre
ramasser les affaires sales et
pourquoi pas aller chercher des boissons
dans le trio des robots et chorégraphe
acrobates une farce heures cette année
dans les magasins de jouets place à la
technologie la star de noël c'est lui le
robot raptor cinq moteurs et des
capteurs sensoriels si je ne mets mon
doigt dans sa bouche il me serre ont
fait pas mal mais c'est nous tiens si je
le cabine et ceci avec la main qu'alain
sans plastique et avoir aussi
d'articulation de rombeau de moteur
et plein de choses comme ça si ce
impressionnant et par furby c'est aussi
le grand retour de for being la petite
peluche interactive par leur réseau les
avoir un allumage
comme chaque année les licences
envahissent les rayons héros de dessins
animés ou stars du grand écran décliné
en figurines jeux de société ou encore
mac est il y en a pour tous les goûts
quoi qu'on pense les plus grands
rappeurs centre et l'est
quant aux grands classiques il reste
indétrônable pour les filles comme pour
les garçons plus d'un mois avant noël
chacun a fait sa liste elle est plutôt
longue et dinosaures oui il rappe tozeur
oui et tout le catalogue
on a tout gâché un peu touche catalogue
presque toujours les bp pas pour les
filles
[Musique]